speaking of creepy sex stuff though
turning to san francisco
the san francisco gay men's chorus
has a message for all you bible
thumping arch conservative slippery
slope
hysterical alarmists they are in fact
coming for your kids you say we all need
lives you can't respect
but you're just frightened you think
that
we'll corrupt your kids if our agenda
goes
unchecked it's funny
just this once you're correct
we'll convert your children
happens bit by bit quietly and subtly
and you will barely notice it
just like you worried they'll change
their group of friends
you won't approve of where they go at
night
to protest but when you'll be disgusted
[Music]
when they start finding things online
that you've kept far
from their site
[Music]
[Music]
and the world's getting kinder genzie's
gayer than grindr
we're coming for them
i think the creepiest thing about this
video
is how talented these guys are
so it actually kind of sounds kind of
bopping along to it you think wait a
second
and you're going and this this video i
believe has since been taken down
because it's elicited a little bit of
negative press as
one might imagine but
the the pushback against the pushback is
oh come on guys
oh you religious nuts they're just
joking they're just come on it's just a
joke it's a tr
it's like well is it i'm
i'm sure that this is in part
tongue-in-cheek you're making fun of the
the fears over the gay agenda or
whatever but
what about this is a joke
we're going to subtly redefine the
standards of the culture
done we're going to expose children to
unusual sex stuff especially through the
internet
true that's that's obviously happening
uh we're going to
encourage them to go out to various
protests for these kind of radical
causes
true that's that that is happening
right so it's as
often as the case in jokes there is
quite a lot of truth here and and then
the question
becomes a political question for the
real political activist radical wing
of the homosexual rights movement
i think there is a widespread belief
that
you should not be able to view any kind
of wild sex act
with moral opprobrium with traditional
moral appropriation
whether that be of jewish sexual ethics
muslim sexual ethics protestant sexual
ethics catholic sexual ethics
even the old old-timey pagan sexual
ethics
that no there's actually there is this
new
sexual ideology with that pertains to
the kind of behaviors you can engage in
your gender identity whatever you want
to call it
and that is the only one that's
acceptable and if you don't go along
with that
you are on the outskirts of society
you should not be tolerated this reminds
me of there was a piece in the new york
post some months ago
about from a public school teacher in
brooklyn who said that it is now part of
a
curriculum in a public preschool in
brooklyn
that you can choose your own gender and
no one has the right to tell you
what gender you are that is a
very rigid sexual morality that your
kids are being indoctrinated into
the most arch traditionalist catholic
school in the world
does not have the kind of rigidity and
and uh make this the kind of radical
claims
that that that public school is in
brooklyn or that the gay men's chorus in
san francisco is doing
a joke but what's what is the joke i
think the joke is probably the truth by
the way also just as a rule
to any other choirs out there to any
other people making musical videos
pride month is over i'm not that doesn't
mean that you can't
express your sexual views or desires or
whatever but enough of the damn
musicals okay we've had it we get one
month a year you can make the musical
videos and they go all around
and and it they often sound sort of
pretty
that's it okay no more no no i'll see
you again next june first
hey yo you you gotta subscribe you gotta
like
you gotta comment you gotta engage i
want your engagement you can watch this
whole episode by the way
uh which is called donald trump versus
hipster rasputin you can catch it here
you can catch it on apple podcast
spotify google play stitcher
myspace xanga all over the place you can
also get my book speechless
controlling words controlling wines
number one national bestseller thanks to
wonderful readers
like you let me know what you think
about it see you next time